auf den ozeanen dieser welt ist kaum
etwas größeres unterwegs
als das containerschiff ms sie oskar
einzig auf der oskar angehört hat dachte
ich mein gott das größte schiff der welt
das riesige schiff ist auf den
weltmeeren zu hause in china ist es
immer stressig wir sind spät dran und
transportiert container von einem hafen
zum anderen
wir können uns keine fehler leisten die
mannschaft arbeitet rund um die uhr um
die fracht sicher und pünktlich rund um
den globus zu transportieren
die ms sie aus gar ist eines der größten
schiffe der welt
sie ist 59 meter breit und 395 meter
lang damit ist sie so groß wie vier
fußballfelder
hintereinander
dieses stahl monstrum ist so gewaltig
dass es neun lagen 1 containern auf und
noch einmal elf unter deck verstauen
kann insgesamt
19.200 24 standard schiffscontainer
aneinandergereiht wären diese container
unglaubliche 117 kilometer lang
es gibt keine effizientere art bücher
über weite strecken zu transportieren
deshalb ist die msi oscar permanent auf
welttournee unablässig liefert
schiffscontainer ab und nimmt neue auf
kaum zu glauben dass nur 24 seeleute das
riesige schiff bemannen im augenblick
ist es vor der chinesischen küste
unterwegs
in china ist es immer stressig
hier gibt es viele häfen und auch viel
verkehr
man muss ständig aufpassen man kann
nicht mal eine minute raus gehen
er muss es wissen kapitän giovanni
capello arbeitet seit 41 jahren für dms
cie die mediterranean shipping company
heute steuert er mit seinem schwimmenden
kohl austin hafen der chinesischen
küstenstadt ningbo
um mit einem schiff dieser ausmaße
inmitten all des verkehrs anzulegen
braucht er einen ortskundigen experten
lotsenboot nähert sich in hafenlotsen
sängerin june
an bord
sehr gut
kapitän wechseln sie bitte auf kanal 09
danke
andrew ist einer der tiefwasser helfen
die groß genug sind die msi oskar mit
ihrem tiefgang von bis zu 16 metern
aufzunehmen
wir fahren weiter geschwindigkeit
von ningbo aus wird die msc oscar das
jenseits der bucht liegende shanghai
einlaufen dann geht es über das
südchinesische meer nach malaysia zum
hafen tanjong paypass dort nimmt sie
weitere ladungen auf bevor sie den
indischen ozean überquert und dann in
einem konvoi durch den suezkanal zu
fahren
anschließend geht es über das mittelmeer
rund um spanien portugal und frankreich
bis zum ärmelkanal um schließlich
bremerhaven und hamburg zu erreichen
eine 20.000 kilometer lange reise die 30
tage dauern wird
doch zuerst muss die msc oscar ist an
ihren liegeplatz schaffen
maschinen laufen auf halber kraft
danke der lotse lässt die fata
reduzieren dadurch wird die oscar
schwieriger zu manövrieren
deshalb fordert er für den letzten
kilometer vier schlepper an
die markierung ja dort hart backbord
hart backbord
[Musik]
lotze und manövriert danke danke ihnen
gute zusammenarbeit
30 minuten später gehen die örtlichen
hafenarbeiter und kranführer an die
arbeit
sie halten den 121 noch sind sie bei den
20 fuß konnten
wir sind fertig
verantwortlich für die ladung des
schiffes ist der erste offizier rémy di
martino wer überwacht die verteilung der
container achtet darauf dass das schiff
im gleichgewicht bleibt und dass der
zeitplan eingehalten wird
wir haben 1400 6 1 und 56 auszuladen
di martino geht mit dem örtlichen msc
vertreter wie ein jumbo den digitalen
ladekran durch das lade verzeichnis
der plan gibt an welche container wohin
muss um das ein- und auslagen in den
verschiedenen helfen zu erleichtern
die schwerste fracht wird tief im rumpf
verstaut
kühlcontainer sogenannte riefers werden
dort platziert wo es stromanschlüsse
gibt und gefährliche oder explosive
güter werden über deck gelagert weit weg
von maschinen und treibstofftanks des
schiffes
gut ich konnte eine frühere arrangieren
[Musik]
während di martino die aufsicht führt
erledigen hafenarbeiter die eigentliche
lade arbeit
acht riesige containerbrücken laden
container ein und aus
wenn dir alle acht kräne einsetzen
kommen wir sicher vor 22 uhr weg
die liegezeit im hafen hängt stark vom
können der kranführer ab einer von ihnen
ist show je einen kran zu steuern dass
die ein videospiel
der kranführer positioniert sich in
seinem kleinen führerhaus über den dec
er identifiziert den richtigen container
anhand eines elf ständigen codes
das containergeschäft genannt scrabble
wird auf den container abgesenkt und
verriegelt
dann hebt der kranführer den container
anfährt den kran zur seite und lässt ihn
anschließend ab
man muss zwei dinge können zum einen
muss man den kran präzise über dem
container ausrichten
ein guter kahlen führer bewegt 40
container pro stunde und bis zu 200 in
einer sechs stunden schicht
beim absetzen muss man den container
dann sicher und akkurat auf die richtige
position bringen
das muss genau stimme
die kräne arbeiten unaufhörlich tag und
nacht sie müssen pünktlich fertig werden
denn jede verzögerung im hafen muss die
msc oscar auf see wieder aufholen
dann eine stunde vor der geplanten
abfahrt kommt das kommando zum anlassen
der 62 megawatt dieselmaschine
guten abend in einer stunde soll der
lotse kommen wir wollten ihnen nur
rechtzeitig bescheid sagen wir bereiten
jetzt wie üblich den haupt mutter vor
der dritte offizielle judo donko fitch
überprüft die navigationsinstrumente auf
der brücke
die bugstrahlruder und die ruder pumpen
wir geben die rote in den computer ein
schalten den ukw funk an und das schiff
ist bereits zum ablegen
eigentlich kann es jetzt losgehen doch
es gibt ein problem die taue die das
schiff am kai halten haben sich
verheddert
unsere kleine war unter dem eines
anderen schiffs
sie haben es gelockert wir wollten die
leine rausziehen so ist es passiert
das könnte die abfahrt doch noch
verzögern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich liegt das schiff ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
godehard steuerbord
dem konto
plötzlich fällt die motorleistung hat
auf der brücke ertönt ein alarm der
kapitän sieht sofort nach was los ist
tief im bauch des schiffes aus
sucht der erste maschinist francesco di
gennaro nach hinweisen weshalb die
maschine automatisch gedrosselt wurde
wir haben einen temperatur alarm an
kurbelwelle nummer 7
ein plötzlicher temperaturanstieg könnte
im schlimmsten fall zum motorschaden
führen
sagt legen ist das kritischste manöver
für den motor das bedeutet wie der start
und stopp als maschinist hat man genau
davor angst
doch der gennaro weiß dass sie den hafen
unbedingt jetzt verlassen müssen also
schaltet er den alarm ab und geht in den
maschinenraum das schiff fährt erst mal
weiter
nach 20 minuten fehlersuche dieses mal
lag das problem zum glück nur bei dem
sensor
offensichtlich haben die heftigen
vibrationen des motors beim ablegen die
kabel des hitze sensors gelockert das
löste einen fehlalarm aus alle sind
erleichtert
es geht weiter nach schanghai zum
verkehrsreichsten containerhafen der
welt nur 100 kilometer entfernt auf der
anderen seite der bucht die einfahrt
nach shanghai bedeutete früher sich
durch dichten schiffsverkehr und
gefährliche strömungen zu kämpfen
2002 begann die chinesische regierung
dann den bau eines tiefwasserhafens um
die inseln von yangon
bis 2018 wurden vier teile fertig
gestellt mit insgesamt acht kilometern
an liegeplätzen die zweitlängste
seebrücke der welt verbindet sie mit dem
32 kilometer entfernten chinesischen
festland am tiefwasserhafen yang fan
werden jährlich unglaubliche 20
millionen container umgeschlagen
es herrscht viel betrieb die msi oscar
muss auf einen freien anleger platz
warten
der hiesige hafenlotse warnt das heute
windböen die ein vater schweren werden
heute gibt es keine starke strömung aber
dafür heftigen wind von achtern der wind
weht aus süd osten parallel zum 4
wenn die oscar auf ihrer steuerbordseite
anlegt läuft sie gefahr gegen das vor
ihm liegende schiff gedrückt zu werden
also lässt der lotse wenden und läuft
den pier gegen den wind an
so hat er mehr kontrolle
am schluss wird die oscar noch einmal
leicht drehen und vollends längsseits zu
kommen wörter steuerbord ein fetter
fahrt aufnehmen
der wind macht das drehen des schiffs
zur geduldsprobe volle kraft voraus
deshalb fordert der lotse drei schlepper
an die das riesige container schiff
ziehen und schieben der vordere
schlepper schiebt den bug von backbord
wenn der bub nach steuerbord wendet hält
er das tausch traf der dritte schiebt
nur
das monstrum dreht sich um fast 180 grad
mit dem bug im wind schiebt sich die
oscar backbord auf ihren liegeplatz zu
sehr gut
gehen wir raus ja
sie begeben sich auf die noc die eine
bessere sicht bietet
der erste offizier rémy di martino
übernimmt das steuer der kapitän hält
sich bereit
er behält immer den überblick wenn etwas
schiefläuft wollte ein
di martino folgt den vorgaben des lotsen
mit schiffs mit chips
dms cie oscar-nacht am kai fest
doch es bleibt kein moment zum
durchatmen
di martino weiß dass die zeit knapp wird
nur zwölf stunden soll das schiff wieder
ablegen wir sind spät dran ich schätze
sie werden sieben oder acht kräne
einsetzen
1340 container sollen mit den 55 meter
hohen containerbrücken auf das schiff
geladen werden ausgeladen werden in
diesem hafen keine
di martino geht mit dem hiesigen
abfertigungs leiter von msi in lahde
plan durch
1 2 3 und 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 und 12 3
insgesamt 17 17
doch manche frachtstücke wie diese
riesigen narben von windturbinen passen
nicht in einen standardcontainer das ist
die sperrgut liste
über große frachtstücke müssen gesondert
eingeplant werden
vor dem sparguthaben ja einige normale
container eingeladen um eine unterlage
zu schaffen
und dass es nicht alles über der turbine
muss ein zusätzlicher stahlrahmen
angebracht werden um sie sicher heben zu
können diese fragt entspricht 10
normalen container daher schwebt sie hin
weil die sperrigen windturbinen haben so
viel platz brauchen ist ihr transport
extrem aufwendig und teuer
über die nächsten 10 stunden heben die
kräne jeweils zwei container
gleichzeitig um den ladevorgang zu
beschleunigen
[Musik]
als die arbeiten fast abgeschlossen sind
überprüft di martino den tiefgang an
beiden enden des schiffs dazu sieht er
sich die markierungen am schiffsrumpf an
vorne haben wir
55 13 55
und dann
gut danke
nach 14 stunden im hafen legt die ms
oscar um vier uhr morgens ab
über die nächsten vier tage wird das
schiff mit seiner höchstgeschwindigkeit
von 21,5 knoten nach süden fahren das
kostet zwar zusätzlichen treibstoff
spart aber zeit
der zweite offizier da caccia hält
ausschau
wir müssen immer auf fischerboote achten
manchmal muss sie oskar ihre
geschwindigkeit stark verringern um die
boote nicht in gefahr zu bringen deshalb
fährt sie die beliebtesten fischgründe
gleich ganz wir können unsere rote nicht
immer einhalten
manchmal verlassen wir sie um eine zwei-
drei- oder sogar zehn seemeilen auf
hoher see hört die arbeit nie auf
teenager und di martino inspizieren das
schiff auf unerwartete schäden
der dritte offizielle donko witsch
stellt gemeinsam mit dem schiffs
elektriker sicher dass der inhalt der
kühlcontainer nicht verdirbt
kühlcontainer sind die wichtigste fracht
an bord sie funktionieren wie ein
kühlschrank darin befinden sich waren
wie gemüse medikamente manchmal
gefahrgut wie chemieprodukte oder auch
fleisch fisch obst
heute hat der elektriker einen leichten
arbeitstag
es sind nur 250 kühlcontainer an bord
platz wäre für 1800
wenn wir viele kühlcontainer haben
verbringen wir jeden tag sechs sieben
stunden damit sie zu überprüfen
morgen wartet ein hektischer tag in
dungeon pippas
die dortige hafen mannschaft muss dafür
sorgen dass die oscar malaysia
rechtzeitig für ihre lange reise nach
europa verlässt
sechs tage sind vergangen seit die msc
oscar in ningbo abgelegt hat nun
erreicht sie die straße von singapur
einer der verkehrsreichsten wasserwege
der welt
nachdem es singapur verlassen hat muss
das schiff nach norden den einen
schmalen kanal einschwenken dort droht
eine strömung von westen die msi oscar
aus dem markierten fahrwasser heraus zu
treiben
sie könnte auf grund laufen doch es ist
die einzige zufahrt zum tanken papers
dem letzten asiatischen hafen auf der
route der
örtliche low zittern garage x kommt an
bord er wird das schiff durch die
schwierige hafeneinfahrt dirigieren
wir haben eine quer strömung von 1,5 bis
zwei knoten und wir müssen eine enge
kurve fahren
es ist ein besonderer tag für djokovic
der dritte offizier wird die oscar zum
ersten mal in einen hafen streit
für einen dritten mal ist das eine große
sache nur so lernt man wie sich das
schiff bewegt wie man mit den schleppern
zusammenarbeitet mit den arbeitern
landtag boot und mit den nutzen es ist
eine tolle erfahrung
dass es schwierig wird
für einen dritten offizier einen
anfänger ist das eine völlig neue
erfahrung
djokovic muss auf 6
man braucht viel geduld
und man muss alles doppelt und dreifach
überprüfen
bei einem so riesigen schiff kann der
kleinste fehler fatale folgen haben es
darf nie zu einer fehlerkette komme
eine winzige unachtsamkeit kann zur
katastrophe führen
maschine stopp
der himmel verdunkelt sich zusehens
[Musik]
[Applaus]
plötzlich prasselt heftiger regen auf
stankovic kann den kaum mehr erkennen es
ist eine herausforderung für den neuling
[Musik]
er will das schiff nun von der bak bord
noch aus steuern kleine fahrt voraus
weiter voraus
djokovic will beweisen was in ihm steckt
maschine stopp
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erfolgreich angelegt für den 24 jährigen
ron kovic war es enorm lehrreich das
schiff unter anleitung des lotsen zu
steuern
es ist ein tolles gefühl
bin noch jung es war eine wichtige
erfahrung für mich
in jon peters muss das schiff für die
weiterreise auftanken und weitere 500
standardcontainer sowie 1.100 überlange
container aufnehmen
der hafen manager john you behält die
uhr genau im blick
wenn die zeit knapp ist besprechen wir
im voraus mit dem terminal nach wie
vielen containern wir notfalls abbrechen
damit pünktlich abgelegt werden kann
die oscar soll in zehn tagen mit einem
konvoi zusammentreffen um den suezkanal
in richtung norden zu passieren wenn sie
ihn verpasst muss sie einen ganzen tag
auf den nächsten warten und zeit ist
geld manchmal ist es besser container am
kai zurückzulassen als zu spät abzulegen
julia zwar gibt den hafenarbeitern die
die container verladen auf die finger
sie benutzten sogenannte tweets blogs um
die container sicher zu stapeln
doch wenn der einfache mechanismus nicht
korrekt montiert ist droht ein unglück
wenn der container hier drauf sitzt
schließen wir das tourist lockt so ist
das verriegelt mit einem twist lockt an
jeder ecke sind die aufeinander
gestapelten container sicher miteinander
verbunden
die ersten drei lagen an deck werden
zusätzlich mit gurten verzurrt auf sie
können bis zu sechs weitere lagen
gestapelt werden gesichert alleine durch
die twist loks ohne sie würde die
ladekapazität der oskar von
19.000 auf nur 13.000 container sinken
die sind sehr stabil das material hält
hohen belastungen stand
doch gignac will nicht blind darauf
vertrauen dass die hafen mannschaft alle
twist loks sauber verriegelt den
nächsten zwölf stunden werden die hölle
manchmal sind nicht alle twist lachs
verschlossen das wäre fatal dann könnten
wir container verlieren es ist die
letzte chance fehler zu beheben wenn das
schiff für die nächsten 20 tage in see
gestochen ist kommt die crew nicht mehr
an alle container an das wird eine lange
nacht
manchmal sind wir die ganze nacht wach
und prüfen container für container ob
die tour ist lachs zu sind
am späten nachmittag ist die zeit fast
abgelaufen
wir haben noch etwa zwei stunden zeit
werden wir bis dahin fertig ja wir haben
noch etwa 50 container zu verlagen sie
liegen etwas hinter dem zeitplan
doch der hafen leiter ist zuversichtlich
dass ihn auch alle container verlagen
können als die letzten angeliefert
werden schätzt di martino alles daran
künstlich auf die minute abzufahren der
lotse ist an bord die letzten container
werden verladen es ist 19 1 ich muss los
eine stunde vor der letztmöglichen
abfahrtszeit läuft die msc oscar aus
es liegen knapp drei wochen auf hoher
see vor ihr bis sie in europa ankommt
und ein gast an bord gehen wird
20 tage sind vergangen seit die msi
oscar im malaysischen hafen dann john
barry pass abgelegt hat das schiff hat
den indischen ozean überquert den
suezkanal passiert und die westküste
europas umrundet jetzt fährt die ms sie
oskar 65 kilometer vor der deutschen
küste
die besatzung des containerschiffs
erwartet den seelotsen er wird das
schiff die letzten vier stunden durch
die gefährlichen untiefen vor
bremerhaven dirigieren doch lotse hannes
schub kommt nicht per boot
wegen der größe des schiffs und der
örtlichen gegebenheiten gehen wir per
helikopter an bord das ist schnell
sicher und einfacher für alle
beteiligten
ein lotsenboot würde vom hafen bis zur
oscar dreieinhalb stunden brauchen der
helikopter schafft es in einer halben
stunde
traum
dem gros auf 15
schon bald ist das schiff in sicht
fliegen
allerdings gibt es keinen landeplatz für
den helikopter
pilot er schalten unser radar aus
deswegen wird der lotse auf die noch
abgesagt
wir gehen an die tür
hinter ist mehr
dann lasse ich nicht überraschen was auf
dem weg nach unten so passiert
und er 15 knoten erste mir die tür
auf der noch erbringen
[Musik]
der hubschrauber passt seine
geschwindigkeit an das schiff an
blödsinn kam zur tür
blut see ist am haken
woods ist gesichert
position ist gut lotze verlässt kabine
bloß wird abgesagt
ein drittel
[Musik]
auch
kloster unten
lotse ist am boden
als und agent
der lotse ist sicher an bord
über die nächsten vier stunden wird er
das schiff nach bremerhaven dirigieren
und
12 uhr 30 liegt die ms oscar am kai
sofort wird mit dem ausladen begonnen
doch man sieht gleich dass hier weniger
arbeiter im einsatz sind als in den
häfen in asien die personalkosten sind
in deutschland wesentlich höher
um die abläufe zu optimieren
kommen portal hubwagen zum einsatz
fahrzeuge die transport- und kran
funktionen in sich vereinen und die
lastwagen und ihre fahrer überflüssig
machen
das wird ein anstrengender tag füllen
hafenmanager henry gebissen
es ist schon mittag und wir haben noch
viele container vor uns dann sehen wir
mal wir müssen insgesamt 5000 abladen
5100 wegen eines streiks fällt der
nächste stopp im schwedischen göteborg
aus wir brauchen mehr keiner
deshalb müssen mehr container als
ursprünglich geplant in bremerhaven
abgeladen werden
wir laden hier rund 5000 container zum
beladen sind es nur ein paar die
arbeiter müssen hier mehr container
bewegen als in den letzten beiden helfen
zusammen
wir müssen bis morgen um 14 uhr fertig
sein damit sie in hamburg die flut
erwischen
[Musik]
di martino überwacht das hektische
treiben
[Musik]
am nachmittag des nächsten tages plan
kapitän giovanni capello die fahrt zum
nächsten hafen hamburg um ihn zu
erreichen muss er die elbe hinauf fahren
das geht nur bei flut weil das riesige
container schiff sonst auf grund laufen
würde
eigentlich wollte der kapitän heute
abend die flut erwischen doch das schiff
wird bremerhaven erst fünf stunden
später verlassen können als geplant
später ablegen deshalb verpassen wir die
flut die nächste morgen früh um 7 uhr
[Applaus]
das schiff muss fünf stunden lang in der
nordsee auf die flut am frühen morgen
warten dann beginnt der schwierigste
streckenabschnitt der gesamten reise
[Musik]
nach langem warten kommt endlich die
morgendliche flut unter den augen von
kapitän giovanni kpn bereiten sich die
lotsen henry simon und ohne jensen
darauf vor die msi oscar langsam über
sechs stunden 130 kilometer die elbe
hinauf zu dirigieren
die warten immer noch vor der
flussmündung wir sind das erste große
schiff das heute nach hamburg fahren
werden
simon möchte am liebsten keinen
gegenverkehr begegnet
[Musik]
wir planen im voraus um nicht auf andere
große schiffe zu treffen flussabwärts
fahrende schiffe müssen raus bevor wir
ein können
die fahrrinne im fluss ist so schmal
dass
zwei passierende schiffe nur eine
begrenzte gesamtbreite haben dürfen
zwei schiffe können aneinander
vorbeifahren aber sie dürfen zusammen
nicht breiter sein als 92 meter im
hamburger hafen ist es noch weniger
[Musik]
deshalb dürfen wir keinen größeren
schiffen begegnen
über die nächsten stunden werden die
lotsen die oscar durch einen schmalen
kanal dirigieren der an vielen stellen
von untiefen begrenzt ist
sobald sie außerhalb der fahrrinne gerät
droht das gigantische schiff aufzulaufen
es ist ein sehr realer anblick wie sich
die oscar gemächlich durch die
norddeutsche landschaft schiebt trotz
der geringen geschwindigkeit ist das
lotsen an bord der oscar
hochkonzentriert
in dem schmalen abschnitt können wir
nicht schnell erfahren ein echolot zeigt
ständig wie viel wasser unter dem kiel
ist die sogenannten tonnen markieren die
tiefere fahrerinnen die ins flussbett
gefräst wurde jenseits von ihnen ist das
wasser zu seicht für große schiffe
vor ein paar jahren ist ein schiff im
sand stecken geblieben weil dort nicht
genug wasser ist man sieht es auch auf
der karte es sind nur ein paar meter man
darf nicht über die tonnen hinaus waren
20 kilometer weiter muss die oscar ihre
geschwindigkeit noch weiter reduzieren
wir müssen auf ein großes
containerschiff fahrten das flussabwärts
kommt dieses schiff hat verspätung also
kriegen wir auch verspätungen
[Musik]
die beiden riesigen schiffe passieren
einander im breiteren tieferen teil des
kanals wir haben etwa elf meter tiefgang
bei dieser geschwindigkeit brauchen wir
2,2 meter wasser unter dem kiel um
sicher zu sein wenn man schneller fährt
braucht man mehr
simon kennt den kanal und die anderen
lotsen genau
viele lotsen arbeiten nach ihrem
ruhestand auf diesem museumsschiff dort
der steuermann ist ein alter kollege
die lotsen sind in ständiger
alarmbereitschaft
als die ms sie oskar nur noch wenige
kilometer vor dem containerhafen ist
kommt hafenlotse peer group an bord
er übernimmt von den fluss lotsen um die
finalen manöver zu leiten die das
containerschiff an seinen schmalen
liegeplatz bringen
die oscar hat die abzweigung des flusses
erreicht die zum hafenbecken für
containerschiffe führt
drei schlepper drehen sie um 120 grad
gegen den uhrzeigersinn
das fast 400 meter lange schiff hat aber
nur 40 meter platz vor bug und heck
dann ziehen und schieben die schlepper
die oscar rückwärts durch das
hafenbecken bis an ihrem liegeplatz
insgesamt dauert das manöver anderthalb
stunden
erfordere schlepper wird uns bei der
drehung helfen und später den bug gegen
die strömung auf kurs halten
hinten haben wir zu einer bremst uns ab
bevor wir einfahren der andere seitliche
und zieht uns rein
das schwierigste ist die strömung
das schiff sicher aus der strömung und
in das becken zu bekommen ist immer der
kritisch
die strömung drückt das schiff ständig
zurück flussabwärts dadurch könnte es
die abzweigung verpassen langsame fahrt
zurück bitte
cook muss die kurve eng nehmen der fuß
ist hinter den tonnen zu seicht wie
carmen rom kapitän
zwei schlepper halten das heck auf
position während die bugstrahlruder das
schiff gegen den uhrzeigersinn drehen
dabei kommt ihr oscar quer zum fluss
strömung
wir fangen vorne an der tuck kommt
gleich rum da müssen wir nicht viel
machen strömung und wind rücken sie
herum deswegen ist die meisten power am
heck diese beiden schlepper ziehen und
aus der strömung
dieser schlepper ist gerade nicht
gefragt sein traumschiff hang klose
durch er ist so sicherheit dar falls
wind oder strömung die oscar abtreiben
wir ziehen sie rein das heck ist schon
aus der strömung vorne sind wir fast an
der tonne
wir sind halt drin
es weht eine leichte brise sie fühlt
sich nicht stark an doch der riesige
querschnitt des schiffs bietet ihr eine
große angriffsfläche
wir haben windstärke 4 auf der box gala
bei einem querschnitt von knapp 400
metern länge und etwa 40 metern höhe
16.000 quadratmeter angriffsfläche
buch voll steuerbar
notfall steuerbord wären die zwei
schlepper am heck ziehen nutzt der
lotsen bugstrahlruder wind und strömung
um den mut zu drehen
gehen wir auf die backbordseite hier
sieht es gut aus
krupp und kapitän capello wechseln auf
die backbord
wir gehen rüber
doch das schwierige manöver ist noch
nicht überstanden
hafenlotse peer group hat die 395 meter
lange msc oscar gewendet jetzt muss er
das riesige schiff sicher durch das enge
hafenbecken bringen
[Musik]
wir setzen bis zum ende des spiels
zurück wir sind uns parallel zum tier
drei schlepper manövrieren die oscar die
letzten zwei kilometer rückwärts an
ihren liegeplatz
[Musik]
dabei kommt sie den anderen vertäuten
schiffen gefährlich nahe
wird es nicht leichter vorwärts
anzufahren
das würde das ablegen aber schwieriger
machen
der liegeplatz ist noch kleiner als
früher
langsam rückwärts die hafen leitung hat
die liegeplätze verkleinert um platz für
größere kräne zu schaffen ja das ist
eine herausforderung
es ist 2
es ist millimeterarbeit das schiff
einzuparken
machine-to-machine stopp
eher sind längst drin
willkommen in hamburg
[Musik]
vom chinesischen ningbo bei hamburg
auf ihrer reise hat die crew der msc
oscar in fünf helfen an und abgelegt
dabei wurden fast 20.000 container auf
und abgeladen
trotz aller schwierigkeiten ist sie fast
pünktlich am ziel angekommen
wenn sich auf der oskar angeheuert hat
dachte ich mein gott das größte schiff
der welt
pyramide martin olsson arbeitsplatz
etwas ganz besonderes darauf ist man
stolz
der dritte offizielle judo kowitz freut
sich auf die zukunft ich liebe meine
arbeit
danke papa ich komm runter
ich hoffe dass ich in fünf sechs sieben
jahren zum kapitän befördert werde auch
der erfahrene kapitän giovani capello
ist zufrieden
für mich war die reise wunderbar die
krude oscar hat 30 tage lang gegen die
uhr gekämpft
ich habe eine wunderbare mannschaft er
arbeitet sehr gut ich bin sehr glücklich
es war ein anstrengender letzter tag
einer langen reise für den kapitän
gehört das zum leben eines simons dazu
von mir aus können wir gleich weiter ich
bin nicht müde ich bin bereit
die msi oscar ist ebenfalls bereit
wieder in see zu stechen
das containerschiff tritt seine
heimfahrt an es geht nach dänemark nach
rotterdam und dann gen süden durch den
suezkanal und zurück zu den häfen asiens
auf einer langen fahrt rund um die welt